IT'S TIME TO PLAY DEVILISHLY
CUTE.
DEVILISHLY CUTE.
( APPLAUSE )
HEY, INTERNET, WE GET IT
ALREADY-- ANIMALS ARE CUTE.
ALMOST TOO CUTE.
WOULDN'T YOU SAY THEY ARE SO
GODDAMN ADORABLE FOR A REASON?
WHAT ARE THEY UP TO?
THERE'S EVIL LURKING BEHIND
THOSE GIANT BLINKY EYES AND THAT
DOWNEY SOFT FUR THAT YOU WANT TO
STOKE FOREVER.
YEAH, AND THEY'RE (BLEEP) EVIL.
EVIL LIKE A FOX.
WHAT ARE YOU HIDING! WHAT ARE
YOU HIDING!
(BLEEP) YOUR CUTE FACE!
WHY WOULD NATURE MAKE SOMETHING
SO ADORABLE IF IT WASN'T TRYING
TO DISTRACT YOU FROM SOMETHING
INSIDIOUS?
WAKE UP, AMERICA!
SO, COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW
YOU A PHOTO OF ONE OF THESE EVIL
CUTIE PIES AND, FOR 250 POINTS,
YOU TELL ME WHAT DARK,
DIABOLICAL (BLEEP) THEY'RE
ACTUALLY THINKING.
FIRST UP, THESE SCUMBAGS.
WHAT ARE THEY-- ( BLEEP ) JERKS.
LIZA.
>> OTTER EROTIC ASPHYXIATION.
>> Chris: POINTS. POINTS.
NEXT UP, THESE ( BLEEP )
BULLIES -- BETH.
>> GOOD AHEAD, AND SCREAM, KIDS,
YOUR PARENTS AREN'T LOOKING FOR
YOU.
AND EVEN IF THEY WERE YOU ALL
LOOK THE SAME!
>> CHRIS: POINTS. POINTS.
SAM.
>> NO SON OF MINE IS GOING TO
HAVE HAPPY FEET.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
THAT'S EXACTLY-- THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
LIZA.
>> LISTEN, JUNIOR, WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO HERE IS CALLED THE
EIFFEL TOWER.
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: THEY-- THEY WANTED TO
LAUGH MORE.
THEY JUST WERE CONFLICTED.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT.
POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
WHAT ABOUT THIS PIECE OF
(BLEEP)?
BETH.
>> DON'T LET THE SWEATER FOOL
YOU.
I LOVE ANAL.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: LIZA.
>> ( BLEEP ) YOUR GIRLFRIEND,
AND SHE REALLY LIKED IT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
YEAH.
(APPLAUSE)